- The one thing I like about Gary?
His honesty.
He's a really good person.
He always tells the truth.
I've never had a meeting with Gary
and I was like, "Woah, I
wonder what he really thought."
It's like, I know exactly what he thought
and he helped me realize what I wanted
to think too, you know?
(slow music)
- What's up, Rob Clarke's group?
It's Gary Vee.
'Preciate all of you.
Hope you guys are fired up about the book.
I think you're gonna be blown away.
Tried really hard.
Last night was interesting.
I hope we get the, I hope we get the
video for all of you guys.
It was just such an exciting night.
Definitely felt like my
strongest book opening, you know?
Big event.
Interesting environment, right DRock?
(audience applauds and cheers)
Kind of like dark, one on one.
Steph is such a great interviewer.
That's why I requested her.
She crushed it, she, you know,
she leaves no breathing room,
you gotta bring your A game,
so I was happy about that.
I've built a company that is a machine,
not me, that can deliver on the KPI
for several different reasons.
First and foremost,
Madison Avenue agencies
are not good at what they do
in a 2016 world and there's an
(cell phone rings)
enormous white space.
- [Stephanie] Can we answer it?
- Yes.
Sis, I'm on stage.
- Why isn't she here?
- Why aren't you here?
I love you more.
Love you more.
(audience laughs)
So, so, I'm able to--
- [Stephanie] She didn't wanna come?
- She didn't wanna come.
(audience laughs)
- [Voiceover] Hey, how you doin'?
- [Voiceover] Excuse me.
- [Gary] Hello.
Yeah, let's do it.
It's all right, it's all right.
- Come on, we'll get you going.
- [Gary] What's up, guy?
(crowd chatter)
- [Riley] Gary, just wanna say what up?
- [Gary] Dude, Riley.
Good to see you, brother.
How are you?
- [Riley] Good, good.
- What's up, guys?
How are you, man, good to see ya.
Thank you.
Thank you, brother.
You know, really excited about hanging out
and doing all the book
signing stuff and selfies.
You know, the guys at the end were like,
"Man, you're really nice."
I'm like, "Of course."
Thanks for coming.
Personal first, amazing.
That's so funny.
It blows my mind every
time I do those things
where people are like, "Oh, you're nice
"and you really like your fans."
I'm like, "Yes, what's the alternative?"
They're like, "Oh, everybody else."
And it's just so crazy to me.
It's crazy to me.
You please, a couple of you
are gonna break out,
follow this blueprint, win,
become something, have people admire you
and care about you, wanna take a selfie,
wanna get the book signed.
Please, please don't become that person
that ever takes it for granted.
Remember where you came from.
- I'm on Anchor because of you.
- Awesome.
Good for you, man, keep goin' at it.
Remember where you came from.
It really matters.
Never, never ever lose that gratitude
of another, even if you have four people
following you right now,
never, you know, never lose
the gratitude for those four.
I think it's very easy and so,
that's kind of the
memorable moment, DRock,
how many people want
to be in line, waited,
after watching me talk for an hour
or answer questions,
wanted to stay in line
for an hour and a half to get a selfie.
Are you kidding me?
That's the greatest high in the world.
- My name is Ari Levine.
I'm the head of New
Business At VaynerMedia.
I help us help people sell shit.
So, I sell shit to people
who wanna sell shit
and make money.
Before VaynerMedia, I came
more from the Startup World,
so I worked at Tumblr, I worked
at a company called StumbleUpon
and I love VaynerMedia,
not 'cause it's an agency,
but because it's an entrepreneurial
startup hustle fest.
Working with Gary, it's a whirlwind.
It's non-stop, it's always moving.
It's always learning.
It's quick decisions and having fun.
- Goin' to do a podcast
James Altucher show.
DRock is doin' DailyVee 20.
We are rockin'.
Snapchat, follow me.
I'm about to get real serious on it.
DRock, I want right here,
you know, like the QR code.
Pause it right now.
Take a picture of that to follow me.
Put the link in the
show, the Snapchat AddMe.
Snapchat, a lot of you are messing up.
It's stunning how many of you,
I just put it on Instagram
and like, 40 people that I've been
engaging with all the time just added you.
What the fuck are you waitin' for?
- Hey, it's Mike Boyd.
I manage a few artists,
Rome Fortune, Richie South
and I know Gary because
I've been working with him
for about eight years.
And AJ.
I met AJ in college and I met Gary
when I moved to New York City, 2009.
I'd been telling Gary
through AJ, who was hot,
which hip hop artists were about to pop
and when I moved to New York City,
Gary tweeted out, "If
you're a real hustler
"and you wanna make money,
"you're about that lifestyle, hit me up."
So, I hit AJ, I was like, "Yo,
"I should meet your brother, bro."
Day I met Gary, he offered me a job.
I took it.
I'm in New York, just
had a meeting with Gary.
About to go to L.A. tomorrow
with Richie South, my producer.
My artist's album dropped last week.
Things are crazy, but things are good.
Yeah, just tryin' to make somethin'
big happen with Gary, man.
Puttin' it all together.
- Hey, James.
Thank you.
How are you, brother?
- Good to see ya.
Yeah, thanks for comin' in.
- [Gary] Thanks for havin' me.
Where are we goin'?
- [James] In here.
So Gary, Ursula, Paul.
- [Gary] Ursula, nice to meet you.
Hi, Paul.
How are you?
- Paul's going produce,
Ursula helped me prepare.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- So, we have the whole team here,
so we're gonna go in there.
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- It seems like there's a direct path,
which is learn, then
create a great content,
then create community around that content,
then have calls to
action for people to buy.
That's what you've done
really successfully with wine.
You spent ten years learning.
You've created content,
which is the Wine Library
and there's a community around that
and call to action, buy this wine.
You're honest about it
every step of the way.
The same thing with social media.
That's how these both come about.
So, what if somebody says, "Oh my god,
"that could take like 20
years though or 15 years,
"like it took Gary, it
took 10 years to learn.
"How can I speed up the process?"
- I don't think anything
valuable comes fast.
So, I just think that my method
is much more tried and true.
There's a lot more of the
Gary Vaynerchuk success story
than the overnight, 24 months, everything
happened for you success story.
- Right.
So, in a lot of the content marketing,
I think the key is
establishing that trust,
so you can build community,
so the community goes from
whatever they're at before
to, oh no, here's the
guy I can actually trust.
That involves a certain type of sincerity
as opposed to, here are
the top 10 things you know,
need to know about wine.
You kind of have to start off with,
here's what I didn't know about wine.
Now, here's what I'm learning.
So, how do you kind of
like, break into sincerity
'cause I think that is the real challenge
for a lot of content marketers.
- I think that's right.
I think that's right and I
think you've got it pegged.
I think the north star has to be truth.
I mean, it's quite simple.
- How do you know it for yours,
like let's say, someone starts out.
They might not have all the knowledge,
but they don't know.
How do they know they're being sincere?
Where's the line?
- Oh, I think they know.
- [James] I don't think there's
a technique for sincerity but--
- I don't think, you know, look.
If you do not know what the truth
or not the truth is within
your own body of your own self,
well then, there's nothing I can do
or you can do to help anybody.
I would say 99% of the
people know the truth.
When you come out the gate
and you're 23 years old
and you wanna be a life coach,
you know that you haven't lived life yet.
That's not super complicated.
When you wanna teach people
how to make money at 23
because somebody who's 53 told you
this is the quick way to make money,
but you know that you've never made money,
like you know that to be true.
- I'll take it.
Yeah.
- [Ursula] Hello.
(laughs)
- Thank you.
Thank you, real pleasure.
What's up, gang?
What's up, man?
- [S.J.] We're stalking in your
Snapchat trying to find you.
- Yes, good hustle.
What's up, man, how are ya?
How are ya, man?
Nice to meet you.
What's cookin?
- Just hangin' out in New York.
We're all from Philly.
- They figured it.
- They saw that.
'Cause of the picture I took on the pad.
Good hustle, real good hustle.
I love it.
You guys, I'm running late for something,
but you wanna quick picture
or something like that?
What are you guys about?
What do you guys do?
- We work marketing.
We're real big on social
media, we follow you.
- Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, brother, let's do it.
We doin' a video or picture?
- Just a picture.
- That's a good one.
- Can I get one more right here?
- All right, one, two, three, nice.
- All right, thanks so much.
- No worries, man.
Got it?
Wanna do a selfie one?
- [S.J.] Yeah, please.
- You got it.
- [James] Gary, I'm gonna say goodbye.
- Love you, brother.
Great to see you, I'll see you soon.
Looking forward to it.
- Thanks, Gary.
- What was your name again?
- [S.J.] I'm S.J.
- S.J.?
S.J.?
- [S.J.] S.J.
- I like that.
DRock, I need initials.
What's up, man?
- Jacob.
- [Gary] Jacob.
Who's takin', we're doin' this?
- Selfie first.
- Beautiful.
S. J.
Don't fuck up.
- [S.J.] One, two, three.
Gotcha.
- Fellas, thank you so
much, I'm flattered.
I wish you well, good luck to you.
You guys keep doin' it too.
You got a long way to go, do your thing.
Thanks for havin' me.
Real nice to meet you.
Stay well, thanks for havin' me.
Enjoy the rest of your week.
Take care.
- [Voiceover] You too.
(crowd chatter)
- I want everybody here
kind of listening to me
and thinking about what
these things that I'm saying
mean to their disciplines.
Right?
The #AskGaryVee book account.
I want looking at all
coms, starting right away.
I don't know when everybody
goes on spring break,
probably starts next week,
of people saying like,
"Getting excited for vacation."
You know, "Getting excited
for my spring break."
I wanna reply to them and say, "Surprise.
"You've won this," and
I want it to be like
"You've won, we're gonna send
you the #AskGaryVee book."
Then, have a hashtag
like spring break book
or whatever we come up with.
(crowd chatter)
Lauren.
Do you wanna see it?
- [Voiceover] Gary,
what's your meeting today?
- How fast I can do it?
I'm a machine.
Because I'm not gonna be able to
communicate with you guys going forward,
Andy, what's most important?
- [Andy] We're trying to talk with
the book publishers for a sequel.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Andy] I don't have a
definite on any of 'em yet.
- Then say, really, literally the show is,
it's just Town Hall.
You just get there and once a month,
third Thursday of every
month at the Beacon Theatre.
It could become a thing.
- [Andy] So, it's like
a performance piece.
- It's like a comedian or
Billy Joel at the Garden.
(employees laugh)
- [Voiceover] Just like
that, just like Billy Joel.
- I really think I'll
do the, I'm predicting
that I'll do the Garden in a Q and A.
Fill it, the whole thing.
Mark my words.
- [Voiceover] That'd be awesome.
- Seven years.
(employees laugh)
No seriously, it's gonna take me,
like I have to do something like Netflix
or a Snapchat show or I'm
gonna need that moment.
You know?
But, I fully believe it's gonna happen.
- [Voiceover] You wanna do Vegas?
You want a residency in Vegas?
- I would do it in Vegas in a heartbeat.
I would do it fuckin' every night.
I fuckin' love that.
I could so do that, just literally,
I could do it in one second.
Just get on stage and like, here we go
and just go.
(hip hop music)
Day before the book.
Midday.
(car horn honks)
Still so much shit that we didn't get to.
You're always leaving something
on the table on these promotions
like months ago.
Even with the whole team, a
billion people on the team,
we still left a lot on the table
and that's just the way
it is a lot of times.
You can't get to everything.
But, the effort was
there and so, I'm happy.
(slow pop music)
- [Gary] Hello.
- [Gary] Yes, I'm here to see Ivanka.
- [Voiceover] Who are you?
- [Gary] I am Gary Vaynerchuk.
(slow music)
- [Ivanka] Hi.
- Hey.
How are you?
- Good, I'm doing well.
Good to see you.
How's it going, David?
(laughs)
I'm like, one day, I'll explain it.
I'm sure you get that a lot.
- [Gary] Of course, it's so weird.
- Like is this an interview?
Like, I'm sorry.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Ivanka] I'm good.
- [Gary] How you feelin?
- I feel very pregnant.
So, I'm due, like now, basically.
Like I could have the child
in the middle of this meal.
- [Gary] That'd be really good.
- (laughs) Yeah, exactly.
Then I would need you,
then not only would you
have to take a picture,
you would have get it on camera.
- That's right.
He's watching YouTube, it's not coming,
she's not as knowledgeable.
She does know that I have stuff,
but I was, I'm literally
walking in my kitchen
and I hear her go, "Now,
subscribe down below."
And I was just like, "This is so cool."
So crazy, so crazy.
- [Ivanka] Do you film at all at home?
- No.
There's literally, you
can't even find pictures
of my wife or my kids.
Lizzie and I have gone really dark there
and then everything else is in the open.
- [Ivanka] I guess
because it's so extreme.
- You know what it is, I think it's a,
I mean, honestly, I think it's,
I think it's, actually, I think it's a
one by one by one individual,
you know, decision.
Meaning it's important for her
and it's important for me.
I want my kids to decide
how they wanna play.
If Misha wants to have
a YouTube show tomorrow,
that's more interesting to let her.
I didn't want her, I didn't
wanna force that on her.
I don't, you know what, I don't judge--
- [Ivanka] Well, you need to turn off.
- Yes, it's good for me.
I like that.
But you know what, honestly,
right now because of this,
I've been getting pounded
on work-life balance
because I'm truly working 18 hours a day.
I don't think people believed me.
Now that there's no
wiggle room in its truth,
people are bashing me a
little bit for not being home.
I tell them like, look.
They don't know that
I came to this country
with nothing and my dad worked every day.
They don't live the life that,
I didn't even know who
he was until I was 15
because he literally left before I woke up
and literally got home
after I went to sleep.
They don't know that Lizzie's dad
was a very successful corporate guy
and traveled a boatload.
So for us, it's weirdly normal.
You know, you can't, you can't impose.
You can't tell people
how to raise their kids
and you don't know
people's work-life balance,
like what their relationships are.
- [Ivanka] Anything parenting related
is to each their own.
- [Gary] I agree 100%
- [Ivanka] You're close
to, the book comes out--
- Tomorrow.
Which I'm super excited about.
- [Ivanka] So, if you wanna send me any
any posts or whatever, I'll post about it.
- Thank you so much.
We will, I will not forget.
Things are super good.
You know, I was pumped that you
got to hang out with Casey, he's amazing.
- [Ivanka] He is awesome.
I love that guy.
- He's the best.
- [Ivanka] Actually,
between the two of you,
I don't know who's higher energy.
- We are higher.
We've done a couple episodes together
and the screen explodes.
- [Ivanka] Yeah, I don't even
know how that would work.
- We're gonna do a, I didn't
tell you, I don't think.
I don't think I told you.
Casey and I are gonna do
a collaborated vlog day
where we're both gonna walk around.
I knew I didn't tell you.
This is where I get to tell you.
We're gonna just cross-sync them
and it's gonna be, yeah,
it's gonna be amazing.
He's amazing.
If I were you, again, and you might recall
this was my thesis on you,
different than Casey and I,
that grew up from that world.
You're an actual, real-life entity,
which makes when you go in there
triple good.
- [Ivanka] Okay.
- Got it?
- [Ivanka] Maybe that would play,
rather than a Q and A that
could potentially be--
- You know what I'm dyin' for.
No makeup, real-life.
I know, you gotta do you.
You gotta do you, but
anything that's just,
like literally, what I think you could
crush on Facebook Live and
this is where it's gonna go,
random, random.
Just like, "Hey, just
had a great meeting."
Hey, it's a big deal.
- [Ivanka] Interesting.
- That, it's just a, look, look.
Dad's winning on people believing,
whether they agree with
what he says or disagree,
they believe he believes it.
He was there for a second.
(slow pop music)
All right, Nate Rossano.
You won, brother.
I like the way you roll with that clever
kind of picture, and
there's me jumpin' in.
You're the winner of the giveaway.
Reddit fans, one hour away from my AMA.
Come hit me, Reddit.
Hit me, Reddit.
What's up, gang?
Good to see you.
Yes, all right, man.
Yo.
I'm literally here actually.
I'm walkin' in the door right now,
I'm gonna go pee, I'll
see you in a second.
We're clearly in book mode right now.
This is the night before the big day.
Tomorrow it drops like it's,
I was gonna say, "Like it's
hot," but I didn't like that.
It drops tomorrow.
I'm very, very, proud.
The early reviews are in
and it's widely considered
one of the great
literally example, I said literally,
liter, what is it?
- [Voiceover] Literary.
- Literary examples of
business in modern time,
according to Tamara Vaynerchuk,
mother of Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is actually a very
one on one personal thing.
If you can get anybody, and I mean
your boy from around the
way or your girlfriend,
anybody that wants to support me,
tomorrow, buying it in bookstores
and Barnes and Nobles matters way more.
Like, we're done with Amazon.
If you click literally on a one to one
and I want everybody listening,
on a one to one basis,
that would mean a lot.
Headed to CNN.
Really just wanna talk
about New York Jets
free agency, but I think they're gonna
be pushin' me towards politics.
I guess I should have booked SportsCenter.
'Sup, Instagram?
In the green room on CNN.
In CNN, at CNN, about to go on CNN.
10:45 Eastern, check it.
- How do you think social
media's changing the game?
I know it seems like a broad question,
but how do you think, Gary?
- It's just attention arbitrage.
I mean, you can't reach an
under 25-year-old in America
unless you're on Instagram and Snapchat.
That's a factor.
It's just attention arb.
This is always what's happened.
If you really wanna go
back to what happened
between radio and television,
that's really the biggest com to this,
what's going on right now.
We are living through a massive
communication shift in society
and people are grossly underestimating it.
(slow pop music)